>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Scott Walter: Good
morning, everyone.
It's a real pleasure to
be here and I really feel
like I'm amongst friends.
So thank you for inviting me.
I'm the Executive Director.
My name's Scott Walter,
Executive Director of CODE,
which is known as the
Canadian Organization
for Development through
Education.
We've been around for some
60 years supporting access
to quality education.
Our vision is one
of every child,
every young person
having the ability
to pursue quality
education and, through that,
to realize their full potential,
really with the belief
that perhaps the best way --
perhaps the only way to really
sustain and generate human
and economic growth is
through quality education.
Our model of development, which
is fairly straightforward,
but is based on years and years
of experience and practice,
is one of essentially saying
that, if you want to make
and support literacy
gains, on one hand,
you need the sustained access
to quality, relevant learning
and reading materials and, on
the other hand, having educators
with the skills to use
those materials effectively
in the classroom or in the
library or in the home.
And then, together with a
focused program of evaluation
and assessment to ensure
that you know what --
we know what we're doing and
that we're improving quality.
So on the book side, this
is a big part of what we do.
Sixty years ago we started
off as a donated book program.
But, thankfully, we've become
a much more sophisticated
organization and really it's all
about the quality
of the materials.
So the what -- the context
we what we're doing.
And, in that regard,
we work very closely
with publishing industries
locally working with authors
and illustrators and editors to
ensure that we're working right
across the entire book chain
and supporting materials
in mother tongue, but also
that it's a sustained supply.
It's -- and I think
that's an important point.
That if materials are not
from that likely context,
it's really difficult to ensure
that the materials are
reflecting the local environment
and engaging children.
So these are pictures of
some of the materials.
We work in about 17 different
languages, local language,
but as well in English,
French, and Portuguese.
We also -- most of -- many
of the materials or much
of the work that we
do is in early grade.
So there's a lot of
work with mother tongue,
but we believe strongly
that the reading habit has
to be one that's
lifelong in nature.
So over the last 10 years, we've
become more active and worked
with young adult
literature and trying
to support the development and
access to material that, again,
will reflect the child's
environment and material
that they relate to their own
lives and what they're doing,
and hopefully be getting them
to become engaged readers
and lovers of reading
as a result.
We work through teaching.
I think this is actually
my older PowerPoint
that I sent [laughing].
But the point is that
much of what we do with --
we realized that the books
on their own are not enough.
That you have to have
those skills for teachers
and educators to be able to
use the materials effectively.
And a lot of that is in early
grades is in the actual teaching
of reading and writing.
I used to work for
the International
Reading Association.
They had a book called "Teaching
Reading is Rocket Science."
And it's an approach
that we believe in
and it's an area that's
been much neglected.
So a big emphasis on the
teaching and the skills
of reading and writing
and insuring that --
also that we're moving from that
rote learning, memorization,
teacher-centered approach,
to the active learning,
participatory, child-centered
approach.
And we have to have a program.
We want to make sure that
there's quality control
and standards and certification
that go along with that,
that we're negotiating
performance standards,
and that we're working closely
with ministries of education
to ensure that that is part
of the national program.
This is an example
of our partner
in Liberia that's
accredited as a provider.
Where we work?
Mainly in Africa.
We're in about eight
different countries.
Very challenging.
We do a lot of Liberia
and Sierra Leone recently.
Very, very challenging, but
we're making huge strides
and it's really one of
the most rewarding areas
that we're working.
We also work in the Caribbean
and part of a newer program
that I really like is
we're in Canada itself.
We're working with
our aboriginal piece,
the First Nation Inuit and
Metis, which share a lot of --
unfortunately, share a lot
of the problems that we see
in the developing world in terms
of marginalization and lack
of access to quality education.
So thank you very, very
much for having me be here.
That's part of a network
that we're involved
with and in Africa.
What a pleasure to be here?
Thank you, again.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.